listen i'm sorry that the weekend's over
but happy monday today we're talking
about marvel's wolverine how you might
be able to expand the storage on your
xbox series x and s in a different way
as well as customization in the reboot
for saints row my name is devonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
so remember last week when playstation
and insomniac blew everyone's minds with
the reveal of an exclusive wolverine
title well good news it's reportedly a
full game following wolverine's
announcement speculation began about
whether or not insomniac's new project
would be miles morales size considering
they're made by the same team well over
on twitter wolverine's creative director
brian horton answered a fan's question
about the game and said quote full size
mature tone so what do you think brian
meant by mature tone are we gonna get a
pg-13 the wolverine type thing or rated
r
logan type game
and now let's switch gears from
playstation to xbox because unlike sony
microsoft chose to go a different route
with expandable storage for the xbox
series x and series s recall microsoft
announced a partnership with seagate to
develop an easy to install one terabyte
expansion card that launched at the same
time as the new consoles since then it's
been a closed ecosystem but one user
might have found a rather simple way to
use a consumer ssd on the latest xbox
consoles detailed in a blog on billy
billy and reported by vgc one xbox
series x-s user has managed to connect a
consumer pcie gen4 ssd to the console
using an nvme 2cf express converter this
converter matches the one that seagate
uses for its xbox series expansion card
which is just half of what is required
for the solution to work it's already
been determined that microsoft uses a
western digital sn530m.2230
inside the xbox series x and s which is
what was used for this mod this might
explain why the console has no issues
recognizing the ssd but there's no
indication on how this solution will
work over time especially since there's
no heatsink on the ssd used but all
right before we move on let me ask you
something why does it seem like jake
from state farm is everywhere the famous
spokesperson went viral this weekend as
users across social media realized he's
included in nba 2k22
as a part of the significant updates to
the social hub the city you can even
dress up like jake we're not sponsored
this is just kind of funny
and speaking of character customizing
volition's reboot of saints row will
allow players to experiment with
character customization in an update
post published to the official saints
row website developer volition shared
more details on how main character the
boss can be visually fine-tuned adding
that it had quote built the biggest
customization suite of any saints row to
date according to volition players can
choose to look like a quote stone cold
killer or a fantastic looking freak show
and there will be eight customizable
voices 4 male and 4 female layered
clothing is making a return and the
vehicular side of the game has a large
array of customization options to go
along with its revamped combat
and now i just want to give a big happy
18th birthday shout out to steem you may
be an adult now but you still can't
legally drink in the u.s so
take it easy be responsible
hit the comment section and give me a
list of everything you want all your
hopes and dreams for that wolverine game
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]